no
[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 argentinas ha lanzado una campaña
llamada argentina te busca con el
objetivo de que quien tenga algún tipo
de relación con el país y dudas sobre su
identidad puedan ser atendidos en los
consulados y conocer así su verdadera
historia y es que aun quedan por
identificar a muchos niños y niñas que
fueron robados durante los años de
terror de la dictadura argentina y para
hablarnos de este tema hoy hace escala
en parís silvina stirnemann que forma
parte de esta campaña silvina bienvenida
bueno esto lleva mucho tiempo en francia
llegó en 1981 con su madre y su hermana
a usted misma es víctima de esa
dictadura argentina que se extendió del
76 al 84 es hija de desaparecido y de
madre expresa política usted nació en un
cautiverio en el penal de mujeres
melchor romero donde estaba encerrada su
madre
esto le ha llevado sin duda a tener un
compromiso casi vital con los derechos
humanos casi no vital sí mucho bueno
durante todos estos años estuvimos
trabajando sobre el tema de la identidad
de el tema de la memoria el tema de la
justicia el tema de la verdad es ahora
nuestro nuestros grandes caminos de
luchas después cuando en el 96 creamos
hijos en parís fue justamente para pedir
justicia por los desaparecidos porque en
argentina aria leyes de impunidad que no
permitían tratar el tema de bueno tener
justicia por lo que había pasado durante
la dictadura y fue toda una construcción
de muchos años de lucha que comenzó con
abuelas y madres y que sigue hoy con
diferentes tipos de campañas de
políticas de estado de diferentes cosas
que se van poniendo en plaza para
justamente que se haga justicia por los
30 mil desaparecidos fundadora de hijos
parís y de la red por la identidad en
francia que trabajo que trabaja con las
aulas de plaza de mayo por la búsqueda
de esos nietos y nietas apropiados por
la dictadura
díganos cuál es el objetivo de esta
campaña argentina que busca y por qué
había necesidad de hacerlo bueno en
argentina tuvimos 500 chicos apropiados
que se llama el jove robado de la
dictadura que fueron robados que son
niños que cayeron con los padres fueron
nacidos en cautiverio en diferentes
campos clandestinos de detención se
considera más o menos a 500 los campos
clandestinos en todo el territorio y ahí
hay en esos campos clandestinidades
clandestinas maternidades clandestinas
con por ejemplo la esma en el pozo de
banfield en el campo de mayo bueno las
abuelas fueron reconstituyendo los
diferentes lugares donde hubo justamente
maternidades clandestinas en ese momento
no se sabía qué hacer bueno entre
comillas no se sabía qué hacer con las
mujeres embarazadas
un plan sistemático de apropiación de
menores que fue puesto en plaza por la
dictadura para recuperar los niños
nacidos en cautiverio y fueron dados en
adopción a familias que estaban había
listas de esperas en los diferentes
centros clandestinos o sino a los
militares propios fueron ellos que hasta
apropiaron muchas veces de los niños
robados de la dictadura y cuántos niños
quedan por encontrar y porque piensan
que pueden estar en el extranjero en
europa o en francia bueno hay 500 niños
ya encontramos 130 y justamente hubo
muchas campañas llevada a cabo por
abuelas durante estos 44 años hubo
campaña con artistas deportistas con la
televisión hubo diferentes momentos de
búsquedas en función de la edad de los
chicos cuando eran chicos buscaban de
una manera en las escuelas después en
las universidades bueno fueron
diferentes momentos de la lucha y es
cierto que encontramos 130 de 500 y
entonces nos quedan alrededor de 350 a
370 y se pensó un momento dado que
podían estar en el extranjero por qué
razón están en el extranjero
hay varias razones primero por las
colaboraciones de la dictadura con el
pse con el franquismo con con los
servicios secretos franceses en su
momento hubo un
un lugar muy conocido en francés que se
llamó el centro piloto de parís donde
venía la cúpula de la esma muchas veces
a francia y hubo relaciones entre
diferentes grupos de poder francés y la
dictadura militar y después también como
argentina es un país que tuvo muchas
crisis post dictaduras y pensamos que
hubo gente que pudo venir en el 2001
gente que viene a estudiar bueno
diferentes idas y vueltas entre francia
y argentina o francia o argentina y
europa porque hay nodos en diferentes
lugares y justamente nos parece que
bueno ahora encontramos uno en españa
uno en holanda y uno en inglaterra así
que es muy probable que en el territorio
europeo haya más nietos me gustaría que
habláramos del procedimiento porque en
esta campaña se especifica bueno si
usted tiene dudas entonces me gustaría
que a partir de esas dudas y qué tipo de
dudas son qué ocurre
bueno las dudas muchas veces salen
surgen de porque bueno los niños
apropiados la característica es que le
robaron su identidad es decir le robaron
su historia ellos no saben que son hijos
adoptados muchas veces
no saben que tienen otra familia no
saben que tienen otra historia pero
muchas veces el ser humano porque bueno
por por razones de semejanza por razones
de historia porque una un familiar le
puede haber dicho algo sabe que tiene
dudas empieza a tener dudas desde
pequeña general empieza a tener duda de
si es o no y muchas veces esas dudas
justamente es un momento dado encuentra
en el camino de las abuelas se encuentra
en el camino de lo que fue finalmente la
verdadera historia de la dictadura que
fueron robados y bueno no todos los
casos hay casos que fueron adoptados o
vendidos en las villas pero pero
nosotros lo que buscamos son los niños
restituir los niños robados durante la
dictadura y esos niños nacieron entre el
74 y el 83 es por eso que toda la gente
que nació en ese periodo que tiene dudas
y que en algún momento pudo cruzarse la
idea de que argentina fue parte de su
mundo en algún momento porque escuchó
que no se que el padre viajó a argentina
en ese momento o algo así puede venir a
de depositar un pedido de búsqueda de
identidad y en ese momento que ocurre se
pone en marcha bueno en ese momento
justamente la campaña argentina te busca
es la nueva fase que se lanzó el 24 de
marzo día del golpe de estado de
argentina y que es una nueva fase que es
muy interesante porque hay 160
representaciones en todo el mundo de
argentina y entonces en cualquier lugar
del mundo en donde haya un consulado y
una embajada una persona que tiene dudas
sobre su entidad puede venir y pedir que
se haga se abra un expediente pero bueno
eso tiene que ser la persona propia que
lo haga tiene que venir llamar y contar
su historia y esa historia si coincide
con los niños que nosotros buscamos va a
entrar en un procedimiento hasta si hay
verdaderamente dudas porque bueno
primera etapa es confrontar con la
historia después es buscar en argentina
los diferentes datos que se puedan
encontrar en los en las diferentes
instituciones del estado como pedirlos
acto nacimiento pedir a garcía y algún
rastro de la persona
en los diferentes registros y a partir
de ahí si no hay si hay dudas si hay
cosas raras si hay cualquier a cualquier
elemento que no coincida ahí se empieza
a hacer el proceso del adn y se
confronta con lo que lo que es el banco
nacional de datos genéticos que es un
banco que creó abuelas en el 1987 y que
fue justamente ha creado y los
familiares dieron su muestra de adn y
esa muestra está a cada vez que hay un
niño que puede coincidir ahí el banco lo
que hace es que mezcla su adn con los
diferentes a los diferentes adn del
banco y ahí se dará la respuesta y
cuánto tiempo puede tomar todo este
proceso y más o menos un año si entre el
momento que uno busca el momento que
porque bueno son procesos que tiene
justamente que encontrar los elementos
para saber si puede ser o no
le quería preguntar también si los
poderes públicos han tardado en
implicarse en esta búsqueda bueno como
le decía en los años 80 hubo las leyes
de impunidad y esas leyes impedían toda
forma de justicia en argentina salvo que
se logró abuelas logró justamente de
mostrar que dentro de esas leyes no
podía entrar el robo de bebé y el robo
de bienes y fue gracias a ese trabajo de
los abogados de abuela que se logró en
al final anular las leyes de impunidad
en argentina porque fue a partir de un
juicio al final de los 90 que fue
condenado por apropiación
militar fue condenado por apropiación y
el juez dijo pero yo no no veo por qué
no podemos condenar por apropiación y no
por la desaparición de los padres y ahí
había como una contradicción esencial
porque las dos están completamente
ligadas las madres que casi todos los
casos de madres que dieron una luz en
cautiverio son desaparecidas entonces a
partir de ahí se empezó a trabajar un
pedido ante la corte suprema de justicia
para justamente llegar a
anula las leyes de impunidad que es lo
que hizo néstor kirchner cuando llegó al
poder
hemos empezado esta entrevista hablando
de su historia
de la tortura encarcelamiento de su
madre de la desaparición y asesinato de
su padre se habla de 30 mil
desaparecidos durante la dictadura y
polémica sobre sobre ese ese número
aunque bueno es sería ridículo no
reducir a un tema contable la
desaparición y asesinato en la dictadura
pero no sé si hay algún tipo de
investigación para saber exactamente
cuánta gente desaparece y por qué no se
sabe aún y no se sabe por varias razones
bueno igual la cifra de 30.000 fue la
cifra que fue destinada que fue dicha
por los organismos a raíz de toda la
búsqueda que ellos hicieron no es una
cifra que viene de la nada en argentina
hubo como decía más de 500 campos
clandestinos de detención en la esma en
la perla pasaron 5.000 personas entonces
bueno cuando empezamos a contar los
diferentes campos cuánta gente hubo
cuántos sobrevivientes hay hay como una
cifra que es que se va dibujando eso por
un lado por otro lado está la conade que
es la comisión nacional por la
desaparición
de personas que ahí fueron que fueron
denunciado más de 9000 casos es por eso
que siempre se dice no pero no es la
cifra de 30.000 porque en la conadep son
alrededor de 9000 el tema es que no hubo
muchos casos que nos fueron denunciados
hubo pueblitos en el norte del país
porque bueno argentina es vasta y tiene
diferentes tipos de represión hubo gente
que no denunció hubo gente que no sabe
que el padre es desaparecido hay muchos
casos así es a raíz de todos estos casos
que no pudieron ser denunciados que
finalmente se logra una cifra alrededor
de 30 mil desaparecidos bueno en su caso
encontraron los restos de su padre pero
hay muchísimos casos que no es
fundamental para hacer el duelo o
empezar a hacer el duelo poder darles
dar sepultura no si es fundamental y es
fundamental también para establecer la
justicia porque el problema de la
desaparición es que es que mucha gente
te cuenta otra historia a mi padre por
ejemplo decían que estaba en brasil
cuando yo era niña y era algo que
vinculó la dictadura entonces yo por
ejemplo sufrí mucho con esa con esa
falsa verdad
y entonces es reconstruir justamente la
verdad de la persona quién fue cómo fue
su historia y darle luz y cultura y
justicia y además también la presencia
del desapareció en la sociedad gentina
era tan potente en los años 80-90 que
era en un cierto modo poder ir
construyendo y poder ir tripulando
nuestros desaparecidos también es
construir una sociedad diferente
bueno pues muchísimas gracias líneas
tiene más representante de hijos parís y
de la red por la identidad en francia y
que forma parte de esta campaña
argentina que busca gracias por su
testimonio les deseamos mucha suerte con
esta campaña muchas gracias a ustedes y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com y en france24 punto com hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]